in this video i'm going to walk you
through the exact anti-routine that took
me from broke to taking home over seven
figures a month in income not revenue
and income by the time i was 28 years
old and that may sound totally
unbelievable to you that's okay you can
google me my name is alex ramose i'm a
business investor on acquisition.com
which the portfolio of companies says
about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you and the reason i'm
making this video is because i see stuff
on the internet all the time of people
talking about their million dollar
routines all the stuff and all the guys
that i know who are like me are like
worth nine figures and up
don't do it that way all right and so
i'm going to walk you through what
people actually do and the things that i
had to go through uh in those seasons of
building that uh are not commonly talked
about as additional note there's uh for
some reason there's like a half second
uh freeze that happens like every so
often on the video it's something we're
fixing on our side but my audio
continues to go throughout so don't
sweat it and we are fixing it either way
um welcome to mozy nation and enjoy the
video all right so what i want to do is
actually walk you through the paradigm
shift that happened in my life when i
went from uh looking up bankruptcy
lawyers to 18 months later taking home
over a million dollars a month when i
was 27 years old all right this is half
a decade ago but there was a very
distinct process that happened that that
transformed my life and it did have to
do with a routine which is like the most
fodder thing
ever that most people uh asked me for
which was like hey alex what's your
routine but what i'm gonna do in this
video is break down to you why the
questions that people are asking are
wrong because they're asking them the
wrong way the first thing here is that
most people have the assumption that
when they say hey alex can you tell me
your routines can you tell me your
rituals that you do every day they think
to themselves there's something that
alex is doing that i am not doing and
therefore if i do those things i will
get that result and i will tell you that
you were wrong and here's why most
people most champions do not have
something that you do not have they they
lack something that you have for a
champion in the physical realm a lot of
times it's they don't have an off switch
they just keep going you have an off
switch it is your lap their lack of it
which is what drives their success right
and so to the same degree you probably
do things every single day that you
should not be doing and so what i want
to introduce to you is a concept of the
anti-routine as the most productive
routine that is humanly possible for you
to accomplish what you want and so
during this 18 month period of time when
i went from almost bankrupt to taking
home a million dollars a month when i
was 27 years old was the following
changes that ended up happening and
mindset shifts so i'll walk through the
mindset shifts and then i'll walk
through the tactics that actually
changed my life in a real way the things
that i stopped doing rather than things
that i started doing that ended up
yielding the results that were outsized
so number one is obviously just shifting
the perspective of i need to do more
things and i need to add more things to
my routine when in fact you need to stop
doing things that you're currently doing
all that remains is the work to be done
and then you become very clear about why
you are not being effective so number
one is that priorities mean
two things cannot be equally important
and here's the mentally challenging
thing about this is that when you work
on something and let's say i spend 30
minutes on this thing and i spend 30
minutes on on item b if i spend 30
minutes on both things and i say this
one's more important than this one i can
say that but that's not reality because
i basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
[ __ ] done because they cannot say
no and so the theme of this entire video
is the word no all right and so this is
the this is the word that i will give
you that you can tell yourself you can
plaster it on your wall is the season of
no and i'm not saying it's forever i'm
saying it's just for right now a lot of
people don't need a new things to add to
the routine you need to have a routine
of saying no and an anti-routine and
that is the thing that's going to yield
those those outsized returns on
productivity you can't say yes to
everything and therefore it means that
you have to you can't do two things with
different levels of importance it's
either important or it's not important
if it's important it means you mean to
say no to everything else all right so
if you say this is the priority then it
means you do not do other things besides
that thing that is how it is a priority
that is how you literally prioritize
number two is that from a communication
perspective one of the things that i had
to really understand and i'm a pretty
people pleasing person i enjoy i enjoy
other people like i'm social is that
when people
communicate with you when people reach
out to you when people text you when
people email you they actually have an
implied ask within the communication
from you it's actually a take and what
that take says is that there's a request
to reply all right they're asking you to
do something which is to reply to the
message and to illustrate why you can't
do this at scale is because let me
imagine right now that 500 000 people
text you do you owe them all a reply the
answer is no because you couldn't
literally do anything else in your life
besides reply to those people if that's
what you did and so here's what's crazy
most people have the time to reply and
conflate the fact that they have time
with the fact that they are obliged they
are obligated to reply and so when i
show you that 500 000 text example it's
to show you that if i can remove the
time from your brain that means it would
be physically impossible for you to
reply you realize that the obligation
reply never existed to begin with all
right and so during the season of no
during this this anti-routine period of
time what i did during that 18 months
was i stopped replying to people and not
only that i'll get to the taxes of how i
did that in a second but i just stopped
replying all together and this was a
huge thing for me it was very very
difficult for me and i'll give you the
actual taxes around what i said the next
thing i realized that all of the events
and masterminds and coaching programs
mostly served other social they were
mostly for social needs they were not
because i had a problem that needed to
be solved and so i ended up going to a
mastermind getting what i needed and
then i didn't show up to that same
mastermind for the next 18 months and
then from there 18 months later i was
like a huge success story in the
mastermind and it wasn't because i got
what i needed and then i spent the rest
of that time executing and there was no
point to me going back because i knew
what needed to be done and it needed
doing and that was it here are some of
the tactics that i ended up implementing
during this period of time that
massively changed my life because it got
me to stop doing everything that i was
doing so that all that remained was the
work to be done all right so number one
is that i changed my phone number i
changed my phone number because all
these people
were always asking me to reply and so
there's the actual time of communication
of the the constant texting back and
forth all the interruptions but also the
hey you got a sex hey can we hop on a
meeting hey can i bend your ear hey can
we talk about this thing hey do you want
to jam on this topic right and as
somebody who likes to give i was always
literally when i looked at my schedule
half my day was like one-off calls that
i was like well maybe this is an
important thing but you would be amazed
at how much blank space appears in your
calendar when you say no to everything
like i like i really wanna like you
would be amazed at how much blank space
shows up on your calendar when you say
no to everything so number one is i
changed my phone number what i did is i
actually gave my phone number to my ea
and i got a new phone number and the
only people that i would choose to
communicate with were people that i
realized that i needed to and then i
would find their number rather than ever
being responsive to every single person
who had mine which over the years was a
lot so that's the first thing i did the
second like i said is i stopped going to
all of these events because i knew what
needed to be done so i didn't need more
information i needed more execution
right so if you look at your own self
it's like do i need more information or
do more execution now if you're ignorant
in terms of knowing what you need to do
to succeed you need to go like what
needs to be done is you need to find out
that information but once you know what
needs to be done anything that is you
not doing that thing is getting in the
way of you accomplishing what you want
number three is that i stopped taking
meetings from 4 am to noon every day i
worked for the first eight hours
completely uninterrupted and it was
because during that first season when
you're you know zero to one million one
million to three million sometimes even
at five million sometimes you're still
you don't have enough leverage because
of your team or maybe the the number the
level of talent on your team that you
need to still be doing a lot of doing
like you can't look at what like my
routine might be now because i have
teams of people that if i if i say hey
go do this and do this and do this i
have 20 people who can execute and those
20 people are going to amount to more
work than i can do possibly on my own
and that's because i have leverage but
until you have leverage leveraging your
time appropriately is what is going to
move the needle the most and so from 4
am to noon every single day i accepted
no meetings and only worked on the
priority which meant i did the thing and
i said no to everything else the next
thing that i started saying no to was i
said no to bedtimes that were different
on weekends versus weekdays i stopped
treating weekends different than i
treated weekdays and i had the same
bedtime so i had the same wake-up time
so that every single day
i could say no to everything during 4 to
12. all right now once you say no to
weekends as a different day to weekdays
the next thing is like what are the
other things that you changed about your
life in terms of allocating your time
what about your health well during this
period of time i only worked out about
twice a week and that was because that
was my minimum effective dose for
working out right because that was all i
needed just to maintain i wasn't trying
to make progress on multiple fronts
because it was not the priority and i'm
saying this again because people always
want to make you know progress on 100
friends sometimes like you have so much
growth juju you only have so much and
you have to allocate it to the things
that are highest priority and if it's a
priority then it means saying no to
everything else
the next piece is like what about what
about food stuff so for me it was
actually more productive for me to fast
one or two days a week because then i
could work and not be interrupted by the
eating preparation thinking cleaning of
food two days a week i would just have
caffeine and bone broth and that was
what i did for the day and it was super
easy and that way i stopped you know i
started starting to
lose a little bit of fat while i was at
it the next thing i did was i deleted
all social media from my phone and that
is because i realized that i could have
an accurate time on my calendar which
was just a post and i could do most of
the apps from my computer so if you're
actually just going there to post not to
consume and interact you can do most of
the the social media stuff from your
computer and that's what i ended up
doing so i deleted all that stuff from
my phone and you'd be amazed at your
like ghost thumb of how addicted you are
because most people spend like three to
five hours a day on their phone
consuming social media it's literally
the new age of watching television and
we're like i can't think about how i can
get the top it's like if you got those
three hours back you would have so much
more stuff done which goes back to the
anti-routine it's not what you are not
doing which is causing uh it's not like
there's some secret magic routine that's
going to get you there it's just that
most of the stuff you are doing you need
to stop
and you need to enter into a season of
no those were the the primary tactics
that i changed during the 18 months of
going from almost bankrupt to taking
home over a million dollars a month when
i was 27 years old and um i know i just
went straight into the rant here but if
you don't know who i am my name is alex
from mozilla acquisition.com it's uh i'm
a business investor we do we have about
uh six portfolio companies at this point
we do about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you i make these videos
because i two was once broke and i don't
want other people to go through the same
stuff that i did and so if i can provide
value to you and make sure that my pain
was not in vain alright so uh enjoy the
videos i appreciate you mosey nation if
you're new welcome and i'll see you in
the next videos